la humanidad agotó todos sus recursos
naturales disponibles para el 2022 y
está en deuda con el planeta hasta el 31
de diciembre todo lo que la tierra puede
generar en un año ya fue consumido para
su beneficio
el día del exceso este 28 de julio
significa que hemos agotado lo que los
ecosistemas pueden renovar en el planeta
durante un año es decir hemos ido a
pescar más peces de lo que los océanos
pueden proporcionar o incluso emitir más
gases de efecto invernadero de los que
la tierra puede capturar y capté con
datos de la onu todos los años la ong
estadounidense global footprint network
mide el consumo de más de 200 países y
compara estas medidas con la cantidad de
recursos naturales de la tierra con el
fin de crear conciencia medioambiental
para la ong wwf
la principal causa del sobregiro es un
sistema agrícola y alimentario
insostenible pues el 55 por ciento de la
capacidad del planeta se destina a este
objetivo lo que en números significa que
estamos consumiendo los recursos
equivalentes a si viviéramos y 1.75
tierras la tierra tiene muchas
existencias por lo que podemos agotar
las por un tiempo pero no podemos
consumirlas en exceso para siempre como
el dinero podemos gastar más dinero del
que ganamos durante un tiempo hasta que
nos arruinamos este año nos adelantamos
una jornada el índice lleva décadas
anticipándose entre 1981 y 2007 el
sobregiro de la tierra se aceleró en
promedio 10 días a excepción del 2020
cuando la humanidad se vio obligada a
estar encerrada por la pandemia